look  we want to make a movie  this can become a cultural phenomenon  the likes we've never seen before well  then we better get started  i know how to make this film  it's a metaphor  for the american dream  this is not just some gangster film it  makes us look like a joke and that's bad  for business this is a story about  family  it's shakespeare  agencies won't touch us it's epic you  want to be a producer bang borrow still  do whatever it takes gangster movies are  dead we will snuff out the hatred if i  say i'm going to handle something i'm  going to happen i'm the prejudice you're  still going to try to make this thing  sinatra wants us to shut the picture  down you got brains  and you got balls  try using both  i can't boost this  what is our opening line i believe in  america  [Music]  you